[MUSIC PLAYING]
TERRY CHO: Hello, everyone.
OK, this is the
last session, right?
After the session, you
may go back to home
or I may have some
drinks with my friends.
Nice to meet you.
My name is Terry, Customer
Engineer from the Cloud team.
It is the honor to introduce
our Stackdriver logging
use case, Samsung.
Before I introduce
our customer, I
will briefly introduce logging
itself and Stackdriver.
OK, let's start.
So what is the logging?
Logging is gathering
event and information
to see the state of the system.
Up here, we just used the
logging for the troubleshooting
and the debugging.
And we collect the
logs into a single file
and monitor by using
the tailing command.
But logging can be used
for the multiple purpose.
For example, for
developer, logging
can be used for the debugging
and code optimization.
For the system
engineer, it can be
used for the health check
and the system monitoring.
For the security
engineer, it can
be used to protect the system
to find abnormal behavior.
And nowadays, data, in general,
is being more important.
So the data can be
gathered through the log
to find the insight.
In this reason, we need
to collect more logs
from the various layers.
For example, we can collect
the CPU and the memory status
from the infrastructure
and the OS level.
And we can get a web
access log from the web
server or the database.
Also, we can collect the log
from the usual application.
These logs can be used for the
multiple purpose, like business
analytics, auditing,
billing, something like that.
Because of that, we need
more [INAUDIBLE] terminal.
Until now, it may be OK.
But the problem
is, system is being
moved to the distributed
architecture,
like microservices.
Because of that, it may
have a lot of log files.
So with a single monitor, we
cannot monitor the whole log.
So what is the solution?
The solution is, we can use
more and more and more different
monitors, right?
But actually, it is
a technical solution.
So I will introduce
a technical solution
to monitor the
distributed architecture.
Here is the general architecture
of the logging system.
We can collect a
log from the system
and send it into the
message queue, like Kafka.
And behind the message queue,
we can collect the log.
The collected log will store
into the log storage system
for the archiving purpose.
And the log will
be indexed by using
the indexer for such a purpose.
So user can search
and view the log.
But the problem
is, as I mentioned,
the log can be used for the
multiple purpose, like data
analytics or system
notification.
And nowadays, machine learning
is more being important.
So the log data
can be [INAUDIBLE]
by the machine learning
system to train the model.
This system can be
implemented by yourself,
where you can implement
this system by compositing
multiple open source.
But the problem is, it takes
long time to log, build,
and you can also bring
a operation of overload.
So what is the solution?
Google has Stackdriver.
Stackdriver is operation
and monitoring system.
It combines the logging,
monitoring, debugging,
trace, et cetera.
If you didn't have a chance
to investigate Stackdriver,
I strongly recommend you
to visit the demo booth.
I saw that there are a
lot of Stackdriver demo.
It is really awesome tool.
In addition, the Stackdriver
can run over the multiple cloud
infrastructure, including the
Google Cloud and the Amazon
service.
Today, I will just focus
on the logging one.
In the Stackdriver logging,
it can support the logging
collection post.
It can collect the log by
using the SDK or some agent.
The collected log
will be stored,
and it can be
searched and viewed
in the built-in Stackdriver
Logging console.
And the collective
log can be routed
to the multiple destination.
Stackdriver can be
worked log router.
For example, it is very similar
to the Kafka in open source.
From the log file, we
can extract the metric.
For example, we can count
the number of the error,
or we can extract the overall
response time of our service.
We define this metric, we can
also define the notification.
For example, if we have
some number of incident,
you can send us a notification
message to the system operator
by using the email, or the
SMS, or a page to [INAUDIBLE]..
And the last thing
is, log management
for the multiple project.
Now this, as I mentioned,
the system architecture
is being changed to
the distributed way.
So the application
can be deployed
into the multiple cloud
project, in case of Google,
and multiple account,
in case of Amazon.
If we have to monitor the all
log row in different project
and in different cloud concept,
it may be very, very painful.
So the Stackdriver can
collect all of logs
into the single place, and
you can monitor all logs
in a single plane of glass.
OK, let's deep dive each
log, into a picture.
The first thing is how
we collect the log.
The Stackdriver
provides the SDK.
The SDK can be easily integrated
with a well-known logging
framework.
For example, in case of Java,
[INAUDIBLE] and the logback
is usually used.
This is the Java example.
As you can see, there
are no code changes.
You just simply change
the Maven dependency
to inject the Stackdriver
Logging library.
It is really easy.
But unfortunately,
sometimes, we need
to collect the log from
the built-in solution,
like a database or a web server.
Or sometimes, your logging
framework cannot be supported
by the Stackdriver.
In that case, we can use
the Stackdriver agent,
which is based on the
fluentd open source agent.
So you can collect the log from
the file by using this agent.
After you collect the log,
you can easily search and view
the log by using the Stackdriver
logging built-in console.
It's really easy, and
it can also support
coding language like this one.
After log has been
collected, as I mentioned,
for the multiple
purpose uses, it
can be routed to the
multiple destinations.
Like Google Cloud Storage, it is
for the log archiving purpose.
And the Pub/Sub can be
used for the log streaming.
So behind the Pub/Sub,
you can put the real time
in our [INAUDIBLE] system or
in some transformation system
for the data permitting.
Or you can export the log
into the BigQuery for the data
analytics.
You can export the log to
the multiple destinations
based on the filtering.
So it means that you can
selectively export the log
to the multiple destinations.
In addition, basically,
Stackdriver logging pricing
is based on the stored log size.
If you have to
store a lot of logs,
it can bring a cost issue.
So the Stackdriver also
provides exclusion filter,
which means that you can
selectively store the log based
on the filter.
And you can save the cost.
Nowadays, the logging
has more meaningful.
I mean, a few years
ago, we just logging
for the troubleshooting.
So the text message was enough.
But the developer
tried to condition
some data, like the user ID,
and the transaction ID, price
from the log.
In that case, the
structured logging format
is more effective, like JSON
format or the CSV format.
Stackdriver supports
the JSON formatting.
This is the node.js example.
If you write the log
with JSON format,
it is automatically met to
the JSON payload element
in the Stackdriver log entry.
And if you export this
JSON log into the BigQuery,
each element in the
JSON payload will
be mapped to the column
in the BigQuery table.
So it helps you to more
searchable and readable.
From the stored log, we
can define the metric.
We already have some
predefined metrics, which
is called as a system metric.
We can get a data,
like a byte count
or the number of log entries.
But if you wanted to
collect specific information
from your log, you can define
custom log in two ways.
The first way is
the counter metrics.
It is a simple counter
metric, but you
can define some conditions.
For example, I want to
collect the number of logs
that web latency is
over than 1.0 seconds.
And the other way is
distribution metric.
It records the
statistical distribution,
like standard deviation,
sum, averages.
For example, it can collect
the average response
time of your service.
And then this is an example
of how you define the metric.
It is really easy.
And with this metric, you
can visualize the metric
by using the graph through the
Stackdriver monitoring console.
There is one example of
the web response time,
and this is a heatmap graph.
You can get some insight
about your system status
like this one.
After we define the metric, we
can make some alerting system.
With predefined
rules, the Stackdriver
will send some notification
to the various destinations
from the email, SMS.
And you can send a notification
through your application
through the Pub/Sub queue.
Last one is centralized logging.
As I mentioned, in
microservice architecture,
each service can be deployed
to the different systems,
and different
products in Google,
and the different
Amazon accounts.
So collecting the log into
some centralized system
is very, very important.
So Stackdriver can
collect all of logs
into the one GCP
product and can provide
single plane of the glass
for the log monitoring.
OK, until now, we quickly looked
through the logging system
with Stackdriver.
But logging system can be
extended for various purpose,
like big data analytics.
It is a way how we can
extend the logging system.
In the real world, when
we try to use the log
data for the big data analytics,
actual data is really dirty.
I mean that it doesn't
follow the format,
and it doesn't follow
the type sometimes.
And sometimes,
the field is null.
So we need the data validation
and the transformation.
In Stackdriver, we
can export the logging
into the Pub/Sub behind
the Stackdriver logging
and [INAUDIBLE] by the Dataflow.
Dataflow is open source
version of the Apache,
which is very similar to
the Apache Spark Streaming.
And it can be used for
the big data analytics.
So you can put some
validation and transformation
logic in the Google Dataflow.
But unfortunately, Dataflow
requires some coding
by using the Java and Python.
It requires little bit
tiny learning curve.
However, instead of
your manual coding,
Stackdriver provides
a template feature.
It means that you
don't need to code.
By a number of clicking in
the Google Cloud console,
you can make a data
injection pipeline.
In addition, if you need to
add some transformation logic,
you can simply
implement it by using
JavaScript, which is named the
UDF, User Defined Function.
So the user defined function
can be uploaded to the GCS
without any packaging, like
[INAUDIBLE] in the Java.
So you just simply unload
it and point it out
from the Dataflow console.
During the Dataflow run, it will
pull the transformation logic
and convert the data format.
By using the
Stackdriver logging,
we can collect the log
from the server side.
But in big data
analytics world, we
wanted to collect
all of user journey,
from the advertisement,
marketing, mobile, like that.
Fortunately, Google
provided us a solution.
For mobile, Firebase
[INAUDIBLE] can
gather all of user
event information
and send it into the BigQuery.
And for web, Google analytics
can collect all of user events
from the site.
In addition, BigQuery itself
has a lot of data connector.
We can collect advertisement,
network data, Google Play,
and YouTube data.
As I know, in this week,
Google announced a BigQuery
additional connector
through the partner.
So now, we can collect
over than 100 data
stores across SNS,
advertisement,
and the [INAUDIBLE] system.
So all of data can be
stored in BigQuery,
and you can analyze the user
behavior from end to end.
It's really cool, isn't it?
No?
Thank you.
OK, the other problem in the
microservice architecture
is called relation
of the log record.
The problem is, let's say that
the user A sends a request
to the user service.
And it writes the log
into logger file system.
And it will send the request
to the other service,
like an item service.
User B also calls same thing.
But the problem is, I
want to track the user A's
request only.
So how can correlate the user
service and the item service
log?
The way is, we can put some code
relation ID, which is trace ID.
So when user calls
the user service,
it will automatically
generate the trace ID
and store it in
the log together.
And the user service sends the
request to the item service,
this trace ID will be
propagated together
and written to the log file.
So by using this trace ID, you
can correlate the log entry
between the different services.
You can implement
it by yourself.
But fortunately, there are
open source named Zipkin.
If you are integrating Zipkin
open source into your logging
system, it will automatically
create a trace ID
and propagate the ID
to the other system.
And the trace ID also
will automatically
return to your
log file together.
Actually, the Zipkin is
not a logging system.
It is originally designed to
support the distributed system
trace.
It means that it can trace
the latency in distributed
system by interval.
For example, I call the user
service and item service.
But I want to know,
where is the bottleneck?
How long time does it
takes for the item service?
After your Zipkin
integrations, Stackdriver also
support the Zipkin by
using Stackdriver trace.
Stackdriver trace will collect
this latency information
and visualize by using
graphs like this one.
This is really good.
But the problem is,
to use the Zipkin,
you need to inject
your Zipkin source
code to your application.
But I wanted to collect
the other system latency,
which cannot be injected by the
Zipkin, for example, database,
web server.
But I wanted to check the trace.
In that case, we can
resolve this problem
in the infrastructure area.
Instead of fixing the
code, we can put some proxy
in front of the service,
which is Envoy proxy.
It is very similar to
the [INAUDIBLE] proxy.
But in the
microservice world, we
need to deploy a lot of proxy
in front of each of service.
Instead of that, istio
made Envoy service.
It can automatically index the
Envoy in front of your service.
So regarding the release of
the application programming
language, you can collect
all of trace logs.
And these trace logs can be
integrated with Stackdriver
service monitoring.
As you can see, in the
microservice sector,
the topology and the
service dependencies
are really, really complicated.
But it shows the
topology like this one,
and it also provides the
important information,
like response time, error
rate, GPU utilization.
OK, final thing is
personal information.
Personal information is
very, very sensitive, right?
If you store the personal
information to the storage,
if it is originally designed
for the personal information
handling, you may
not have a problem.
But sometimes, unexpectedly,
the PII or user information
can be stored in
your logging system.
It is critical.
To prevent that, we
can use the DLP API--
Data Loss Prevention-- which
is based on the Google machine
learning technology.
It can automatically detect
the user information,
like social security
number, what
are some other information.
And it can anonymize,
make it as a hash value.
So it can prevent
personal information
to be stored in
the logging system.
OK, from last year, by using
the Stackdriver logging,
Samsung started to
move to the innovation
to SRE and the DevOps practice.
So today, I will introduce head
of Samsung mobile operations
systems, Jin Lim, to stage.
Jin, it's your turn.
HYUNG JIN LIM: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
All right, it's
great to be here.
It's an honor to
actually present
my presentation in Google Next.
Coming to this large
tech conference, for me,
is really a treat for me.
I remember my first big
conference was about nine
years ago, and I was
infrastructure engineer,
service engineer with
this big software company.
And at the time, it was
about the Cloud Conference,
and it was really
eye-opening for me.
Because as an
infrastructure engineer,
whenever an engineering
team asks me
to deploy, provision
new software
in the traditional data center,
it takes about three months.
I think it's industry standard.
Whenever you try to deploy new
software in a traditional data
center, it takes
about three months.
But then in this
conference, they tell me,
I can provision in
a number of servers
in less than 10 minutes.
And it was like, this
is where I need to be.
With my career, I
want to be in a cloud,
and I'm trying to
do more of work.
It makes my life easier and
helping our engineering team
as well.
That sort of feeling I had
with the Google Next this year
as well.
When I hear about Anthos, it
was like a new world for me
as well.
Because I've been trying to
move some of our legacy systems
into a [INAUDIBLE] and be
more efficient, more flexible.
And it was really hard
to get a lot of time
from our engineering
team asking code changes.
But then this Anthos, we're
able to do that without code
changes, and it's free.
So it's really great to
have those kind of future
come into industry as well.
Have you guys heard company
name Samsung Electronics?
[LAUGHTER]
OK, good.
I'm pretty sure you guys know
about Samsung Electronics.
We create or build pretty
awesome consumer electronics,
including handset devices--
very innovative.
And we have a list of business
inside of Samsung Electronics.
Back in Korea,
Samsung is not only
about consumer
electronic manufacture.
We are in business of
construction, insurance,
and a theme park, hotel,
and many more of business
we are in in Korea.
They said it's easier to
list out the businesses
that Samsung is not in
compared to what we are in.
This huge technology company
has a tremendous value
in their name.
And for most of
college graduates,
it is dream job to
come into Samsung
and work for the company.
Because one of the reason
is good pay, of course,
and provides job security.
The reason is, we have such
a big portfolio of business
sectors that if there is a
downturn in one business,
we can ship those people.
We don't have to lay people off.
What I mean is, we ship
some of those people,
moving them into
another business sector.
So with Samsung,
with a big company,
you have a pretty good level
of job security as well.
And for some of the folks,
it'll be great opportunity
to work in a global environment.
You get to talk to a
lot global, smart people
and try to learn your way in
a career, trying to understand
from the global environment.
So that's another
advantage those college
kids want to have as well.
But then I'm pretty
sure it was only recent
that Samsung is also starting to
be known as a service company.
So I have a list of
this application service
that we are running,
trying to add more value
to our smartphone devices.
For example, Samsung Pay is,
in my opinion, most innovative
service that we ever created
in Samsung electronic,
providing digitalized
credit card or bank
card into your phone.
And you can virtually
pay using this phone.
You can pay anywhere
that you want to pay,
including if this
point of sale device
only accepts the MST,
which is a magnetic only,
you can still use
Samsung Pay devices
and Samsung pay
services to pay with it.
It's a huge success in Korea
and some of the other country
as well.
We have Samsung Account.
We have Samsung Pass, which
is a biometric authentication
mechanism, where, as
long as you have a thumb,
and when you are trying
to access network
resource with your log-in
information and password,
after that information
saved in the phone,
you don't have to
memorize that anymore.
So that information's securely
saved into your devices.
All you need is the
thumbprint to access
any of your network resources.
And we are also in
B2B business, and we
provide [INAUDIBLE] like
solution for Android devices,
trying to work with our partner
in different business sectors.
I'm going to show
you a little bit more
about the Samsung AI
system called Bixby.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- Say hi to the new
Bixby, Samsung's
intelligent assistant.
- Hi, Bixby.
What's on my schedule
this afternoon?
- You have one event
scheduled today at 1:00 PM--
meeting with pattern maker.
- Change this event
time to 2:00 PM.
- All set.
I saved the event.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- Hi, Bixby.
Find Italian restaurants nearby.
- Here are some Italian
restaurants nearby.
- Get me a table for three
today at Luciano's at 1:00 PM.
- You're all set for lunch.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- Hi, Bixby.
Get me an Uber to work.
- The fare for this
ride will be $21.72.
Ready to request ride?
- Perfect.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- Hi, Bixby.
It's run time.
- OK, turning on Bluetooth.
Starting a run in Samsung
Health, playing Run playlist.
[END PLAYBACK]
HYUNG JIN LIM: All right,
that's about the Bixby.
Today, about 57 million
registered users
are utilizing Bixby services.
And with the latest
version of Bixby service,
we are supporting Korean,
English, and Chinese.
And already this year, we
added five more languages
that most of European
uses it today.
This year, next
year, we're going
to keep on expanding,
supporting different languages
on the global.
And with 2.0 changes
that we made with Bixby,
the huge change is we
are trying to open our AI
system to our partners.
We provide the same
machine learning tool
that we are using in
internal, and we're
providing to our partner
to utilize that as well.
And not only partners.
As long as you are
developer and as long
as you know how to
use our tool, you
should be able to
integrate it with Bixby,
sort of like Play Store that you
can upload your app into Play
Store.
You can do the similar thing
with the Bixby Development
Portal.
So do find out more from
the Bixby Department Portal.
If you want to reach 57
million users for your business
and including-- it's not
only the handset device.
It will be TV and refrigerator.
Any consumer electronic device
can connect to our network.
We will integrate with
Bixby in the future.
Next, my colleague
Jooyoung will be explaining
about what are the challenges
that we've been having managing
Bixby big size of log with the
50-plus size of microservice
we are running today, and
then how Stackdriver helps us
to addressing some
of those problem.
Jooyoung.
JOOYOUNG HWANG: Hello, everyone.
My name is Jooyoung, and
I'm the DevOps member
in the Bixby project.
It's a really honor to
present my experience here.
I hope that our small experience
can give you the opportunity
to understand how we
overcome that situation
about the logging, and it will
be a good technical reference
for you.
Yeah, let's get
into the background.
Actually, we have the
new Bixby services now.
It means that previously, we
have another Bixby services.
Usually, when we call
about the logging system,
the logging system is
usually for the debugging,
and the monitoring, and also
the analysis purpose, too.
But with the small size of
the project or the services
can consider that, maybe just
to use the ELK for the logging
system, or some kind of
just open source solutions
to overcome the situation.
However, some services that is
for customer service or larger
scale services always try to
build their own logging system.
That is for reliability
and scalability, too.
And currently, the new
Bixby, the log data
is almost 1.5 terabyte per day.
And we have to
think about how we
can satisfy the real-time
monitoring with using
our current internal
logging system.
And also, we have to
guarantee that the reliability
and scalability, too, for
the customer services.
So when we think about
the previous logging
system in Bixby services,
the major key point
was that logging for
debugging, and the other one
is the cost of saving point.
Actually, the previous
internal logging system
was developed by ourselves.
And that means that that is not
known solutions in the market.
It was designed in our side and
developed in our development
team.
And that is deployed to
the cloud infrastructure.
And mostly, all requirement was
driven by our internal users.
So it is more easy to
satisfy all the requirements
when we develop ourselves
for the logging system.
However, when we want
to add new features,
like the tracing or
E3 testing, then we
have to change our
infrastructure and the design
concept of the logging system.
But that system was not
designed at that time.
And simply, they logged all log
messages into a logging system,
and simple monitoring was
only supported by the Grafana.
So we have some challenges.
How we can provide the tracing
mechanisms to the developers
to give some help how they
can debug the issues when
some issues are detected
in their own applications?
And indeed, when we are
adding the new logging system
into our cloud infrastructure,
the complexity of the system
goes much higher
than we expected,
and it is not easy to
add in new features
to the new logging system.
As well as the cost
also goes up high.
And the cost was one of
the big challenges for us
to reduce the costing fee.
So that is the
major tool request
for the DevOps team side.
And we have to
change, or we have
to find out any solutions
available in the market.
So we gathered some suggestions
from the other team.
That wasn't at the [INAUDIBLE]
of Google, actually.
We searched the Stackdriver
in the Google at the website,
and we found that
we have to check
that what is our key feature
for providing the new logging
system.
So firstly, we have to think
about the real-time monitoring.
Stackdriver supports that
real-time monitoring is
based on the log-based metrics.
The logging system is
using the Stackdriver.
It also can support the
real-time monitoring.
But it has also
provided easy ways
to integrate with the
other monitoring solutions.
In the Bixby 1.0, we have the
internal monitoring solution,
and that is also have
to be continuously
to use for our operations.
So we have to check whether
the Stackdriver can support
the third-party monitoring
solution integration,
and we can guarantee
that that is possible.
And second, the most important
thing on the logging system
is the experience of debugging.
So now, our previous
logging system,
when developers want
to search any logs,
only the application-driven logs
can be searched at the time.
The one problem was, all
the developers cannot make
the standard log
format at a time.
And a huge number of
developers in Samsung
was involved in this
Bixby development,
and they made it
their own style.
We made log messages.
It doesn't show any
related log messages
for debugging purposes.
So it means that developers want
to check whether a new detected
issue belongs to their problem
or to another other module's
problem.
We have to provide any tracing
mechanisms to developers
for providing the easy
ways to search the log
messages for debugging.
So when we checked
that the Stackdriver,
it also can support
the tracing mechanisms
as using the automated trace.
However, it cannot be applied
to our internal requirement.
Actually, if we want to add
the auto-created tracing ID,
we have to persuade
all the developers
to apply that requirement
to their source code.
It is not easy.
I think some of you are
working in the big company.
The big company have
several organizations.
And even though that
organization only
belongs to the development,
the development team
have their own
strategy and policies.
It is not easy to
add in the new code
for only the tracing
purpose into their code.
Because they worry that any
side effect and any performance
degradation due to
adding the new mechanisms
to their own code.
So we have to make sure
that tracing is also
need to be adding a
new logging system.
And we made a new
standard log format
to apply the Stackdriver.
And secondly, previous
logging system
also provides that the
analytics of the system.
It means that some of the log
messages should be gathered,
and that is sent to
another analytics platform.
And that platform is
gathering all data
and providing the analysis data.
We have to make sure
that the Stackdriver have
to support that,
and we had to check
whether that is available.
So after checking that
all the requirement,
we can go with the Stackdriver
without any building
the internal logging system.
Internal logging system usually
requires too much effort
to develop.
And also, we cannot satisfy
that all the project milestones
to go forward.
So now, we could do that.
We have to do that about the
log format standardization
to satisfy that tracing purpose.
The other one is that, usually,
when we build a new logging
system, always, we have to
think about the user management.
So when we use the Stackdriver,
all the user authentications
or user management is
[INAUDIBLE] by the IIM policy.
And the Stackdriver
log viewer is basically
supported so that every user who
gets the permissions to access
the log viewer pages,
then they can immediately
search the log messages
by accessing the console.
And the most important
thing is that some
of the infra-related
system metrics
is automatically created
by the Stackdriver agent,
and it is sending to the
Stackdriver services.
But we also need another
custom metrics too,
which is generated from
the application side.
So one of the things
about the Stackdriver
is that they can support
log-based metrics.
And even if we can communicate
with the other application
developers and we can define
that any metrics in that
log messages, that it can
gathered by the filtered--
the log-based metric.
And it is that one of the
materials for the operation
and monitoring.
So now we have the
simple diagram.
So all logs, which is
stored in the each modules,
is gathering by the servers and
from the Stackdriver Logging
agent do that all
the data is gathering
and transfer that data to
the Stackdriver service.
And then we can integrate
with the Datadog, one
of our major
monitoring solutions,
and that is gathering all
the log-based metrics.
And it can show the one unified
format of the dashboard.
It is the-- currently, we are
not going to the SLA practice
yet.
So we have the traditional
operation practices
now so that every tier one
and tier two and even the tier
three is using that
to get any issue
detection by our own dashboard.
Also, we also use the
Stackdriver monitoring tool too
because that dashboard is also
providing any custom dashboard
creation.
And that also can be integrated
with the other solutions,
like the open source Grafana.
And we have used
the Slack channel
to notify every warning or the
complication for convenience.
And if we can define
that any alert
in the Stackdriver
and the data row,
then it can automatically
send that Slack channel,
and then it can goes
to the stakeholders
to investigate any issue or for
notify any operation process.
Basically, the debugging
also can be available
when we access the log viewer.
And for analytics purpose,
we are gathering all the log
messages and filter them
into the Google Cloud Storage
services.
And it is going to the
analytics system by Pub/Sub.
So finally, we can say
that, after applying
the Stackdriver
for logging system,
we can have the four
number of effectiveness
after using that Stackdriver.
Firstly, we can talk
about the cost saving.
We can say that at least three
times lower than a cost saving
was possible when we
used the Stackdriver.
So it means that we
don't need to think
about any infra-changes or
maintaining the system, only
that we can give all effort
to service reliability
and scalability.
And it means that secondly, we
can minimize all the workload.
So we don't need to think
about any maintenance
about the logging system.
We can fully give the energy
to service reliability.
Three, when we use
the Stackdriver,
we also realize that
unified this logging system
can be applied to
another project
if that requirement is really
similar with the Bixby project,
so that our operation team
has much number of services,
as Jin mentioned.
So that, if it is
possible, we can
add Stackdriver to
the other services
as the unified platform
of the logging system.
Finally, we also-- even though
we integrated with the analysis
data system
internally in Samsung,
but better scalability.
And another purpose
of the data analysis
also is possible when
we're using the BigQuery.
So this is my last page.
So I will back to Jin.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
HYUNG JIN LIM: Right.
I know this last
session, and I know
you are eager to go back to
your, you know, home and so on.
But I'll make it
quick as possible.
But it is my talk
that I wanted to do--
practicing SRE, trying to make
that happen in our environment
as well.
So let's see.
So some of the challenges as
in Samsung Electronics we had--
I joined the company in 2013.
I came from the large
software company
based in Redmond, Washington.
I spent about 10
to 12 years there.
Got hired by Samsung and
moved my family to Korea.
And back then, there were
some other guys like me
who came from global
software company.
And then Samsung wanted to
make them an environment where
software development
management is
kind of normal to our company
because the company has not
came from a software base
in their core business.
Their core business
is manufacturing.
So they are trying to
create an environment,
trying to create a culture
of software development.
But then, as the company
put more investment
on software development, we
created more service as go on.
Every time we add more
services, obviously, there
will be more people to operate
those services as well.
So as, you know, services, being
more added to the production
environment, we need more
people to operate and support
those services.
The problem is, we
feel that we're not
going to be able to
justify ourselves
of growing rate of
operation team any longer.
So we need to think about new
way of operation still able
to support a number of services
coming into production.
As I'm being with
Samsung, I'm kind of
lucky enough to witness
all the changes being
done in the software management
inside of Samsung as well.
As you can see, you
know, box product, right?
So we ship-- we release flagship
devices every six months,
right?
We have S series.
We have Note series.
It takes about six months.
Waterfall methodology of
development lifecycle kind
of makes sense in box product
in a manufactured system.
And we have all the
important decisions
is being made by executives
since we have enough time
of lifecycle of these products.
And obviously back
then, we utilized
a lot of traditional data
centers to host our servers.
And all the system is sort of
like a monolithic architecture
system.
But then over the
year, we know we
can't do this type of management
any more with the service
development.
So we change ourselves to Agile
coming from the Waterfall,
where we break
down all the tasks.
We create a backlog and we're
trying fulfill back-- you
know, given the right
engineer to actually be
responsible for those backlogs.
And we run every spring and
trying to ship out at the end
a shippable product
to production.
And all the decisions is
now made being made by a PO.
Or every key feature
in production,
whether it needs to
be going live or not,
being decided by
our product owner.
And obviously, right now,
majority of our servers
are being hosted in a cloud
unless there are compliance
that the server has to be in
a traditional data center.
And you know, why going with
this pattern of the making
breakdown each feature
in the production?
It makes sense to architect
ourself as a micro-services
instead of the monolithic.
Still, in an old way of
the development lifecycle,
as I mentioned, we have six
months of time on Waterfall.
And we could have all the time.
Every time we have new
service coming in, we can--
as an operation, we can find
ourselves to ask engineer team,
create an operation
guide, KB article, and do
the right training team what's
coming into a production
environment.
And it all makes sense.
But then with the project
managed by Agile and Sprint,
we don't have that
luxury anymore.
We don't have time to ask them.
Or engineering team
does not have a time
to provide all
those information.
So we also have a
conflict between business
and the engineer and
operation, where our priority
is providing a stable
service to our customers,
where engineering team is
trying to push new value
to our production environment.
So we're continuously
having this conflict.
While we're trying to
solve this operation
conflict and the
organizational challenge,
we came close to chance
to work with the Google
engineer, Google SRE engineers,
and trying to learn more
about SRE practice and how
Google does their SRE practice
in their end.
And we ran through a lot
of meetings and seminars
with the Google engineers.
But then we realized that
Samsung is not Google.
So what I meant is that we
didn't come from a software
development company.
We came from the very
process-driven manufacturer
culture in the back of our mind.
So next thing that
we did was, OK,
so we understand what SRE can
give us, what kind of benefit.
But then we need to
answer how question.
How can we implement this
practice to our environment?
So we can start learning
from other industry leaders
in practicing SRE.
We learned from
Netflix, LinkedIn, Uber,
and many others.
And they all have something
in common too, right?
So they break down
to each kind of--
separate what's
put into production
and separate who should be
responsible for addressing
those issues.
They have a notion of
you build it, you run it.
So if there is a
developer who is trying
to push into production,
and that person
is supposed to know how to
troubleshoot those issues, not
operation engineers.
So we really like those notion
of the movement there as well.
So we came up with our
own version of SRE.
We call it ourself as a
global service reliability
engineering.
And we break down to a different
area of implementation.
So before, pretty
much every service
that we are running
today does have SLA.
We do have a key
index of availability.
But then that's not
enough for SRE practice.
We want to make sure
we kind of break down
to each function
within the service
and making sure each function,
user impacting function,
does have an SLO, SLI.
And also, we want to
make sure that the error
budget is being communicated
with the engineering team.
So if you exhaust
all your SLO, then we
will focus on making
the reliable system
instead of pushing new
idea into production.
This is one example of
an SLO document we have.
As I mentioned, you know,
big service such as Bixby
has a different functionality
capability within the service.
One of its capability is ASR,
which translates the utterance
to text.
So we create this
template where we break it
down to an application level
as an ownership of that SLO
is primary ownership
of SLO is that.
We have underneath
a primary ownership
of operation, which is us,
managing infrastructure
level of SLO.
And one of the key
points is infrastructure
SLO is much tighter, higher
than application SLO.
Obviously, you know,
application SLO
could not be made if the
underlying framework is not
there yet, right?
So that's why we're trying
to kind of differentiate
between operation primary
responsibility and engineering
primary responsibility.
With the Stackdriver
and Datadog,
we were able to create the
dashboard just for that SLA.
So based on this SLA, if there
is a SLA, SLO threatening
event that is happening,
we can integrate
with the Datadog and Slack and
some other alerting mechanisms.
We can give the alert
to the right engineers.
And also, that comes into
instance management as well
And before we take traditional
multi-tier escalation path,
right?
We have tier one,
tier two, tier three,
which is essentially developers.
If issue happens,
tier one catches it
and escalates to
tier two if they
don't have enough information
how to troubleshoot.
And tier two in operation
side is supposed to know,
you know, most, you know,
how feature is running
in a production environment.
But if, in the name of the
Agile and the service, you know,
as I mentioned, there's
always lack of information
what are running in a production
and application level.
So we ended up calling developer
pretty much every time.
So if you think about SLO
of 395 for availability,
you have only 22 minutes
of allowed downtime.
So in the middle
of the night, one
of instances
happening like this,
it's easy to lose
about 30 minutes.
So for that month, if we
have a single instance,
you are violating SLO.
So we needed to take a different
approach in SRE, right?
So we're trying to
pinpoint the actual error
and do a better
job in our logging.
We may not have to go through
the tier one and tier two.
If system generates
the right information
and push those alerts
to the right engineer,
it could be a
developer because event
is trying to violate
the SLO for application.
You could go to our
infrastructure engineers
if it's violating some SLO
that we pre-built for network,
right, for example.
So we can pinpoint the alert.
And we can finish up doing--
we bypassed multi-tier
escalation there.
This I need to finish
up really quick.
Deploy management.
You know, same idea.
Operation team used
to own deployment
of production environment.
We call ourselves as a
production engineer, right?
So we have ownership of making
stable and [INAUDIBLE] there
for business looking
and customers looking.
But then as we're
separating out with the SLO
for developer and
operation engineer,
now we are making
the infrastructure
as a code,
configuration as a code.
Operation have ownership
of pushing new changes
if it's a configuration
and infrastructure.
Development team have
ownership of pushing new code
into production.
And that way, you know, we
don't have to stop development
to deploy new code
into production asking
for a bunch of KB article
to how to troubleshooting
because this alerting,
when they push new idea
and if there is a
problem, the alerting
will go straight
to a developer, not
to operation who knows
nothing about those changes
in the code.
Cultural change is lasting,
but it's not listening.
This is the hardest
thing to do, right?
So we can communicate
this to our leadership,
and they all get the idea.
And you know first
comment was, you know,
cultural innovation,
you need to talk
to make sure all peoples
are in the consensus, right?
So we are starting to do a
lot of [INAUDIBLE] seminars
with the front engineering
team pushing this idea
and make sure they're onboarded.
And we asked what
needs to be happening
and what help we're going to
be needing from them as well.
And some other
things that we did
was we create a
task force, right?
So we create a task
force or dedicate a team
to create the toolset, right?
We don't do
application deployment,
we provide the pipelines,
CI/CD pipeline,
that gradual change is
embedded into a pipeline.
Risk management is
embedded in the pipeline.
It's a no brainer for
our development team
that if they're trying
to push a new idea
but if it's starting to having
problem, it's easier for them
to go back as well.
So we're trying to create a
team providing this type of tool
to engineering team as well.
So that same goes with your
logging and monitoring.
And QA automation-- we don't
have QA automation, security
automation, yet.
We have this multi-plan
organizational change
and trying to fit into
this model of SRE.
And while we're
trying to provide all
across the same
toolset for our SRE,
we also have a service SRE
who are actually working
on the project, trying to plug
in those platform solutions
into actual services as well.
I can't really say
all the benefits
we are having right now
because we are still
on the stage on
the adopting SRE.
But then we are
kind of expecting
to have a better visibility of
our service with the measuring
everything that
happening in a production
and reducing mean time to
recover, obviously, right?
So trying to meet the SRO
and reduce the release time
with the CI/CD
pipeline automation
and optimize operation
resource as well.
So I think this is
my last session.
Thank you for joining us, and
you may go to your family now.
[MUSIC PLAYING]